non possono farli tutti così menu di
videogames l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti
a questo nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi
visto che è finito il side cominciamo
una nuova serie dice come sono stato
teatrale ragazzi mi avete martellato
bene durante l'ultimo periodo per farmi
fare life in strange allora io vi giuro
su me stesso che io non so un cazzo cioè
nel senso sto gioco e famosissimo però
non ho mai giocato non mai neanche visto
niente non ho letto neanche l'altro non
sa neanche di che cosa tratta però avete
consigliato tutti sarà figo possono
essere tutti i deficienti che bei
ragazzi alla premi un pulsante io premo
la cooper che sono tra sgretolata giugno
tutto in italiano
pure godibile commenti dei registi alla
madonna va bene tanto ragazzi ho visto
che eyed pease o di 15 sono più episodi
questo il primo nuova partita e va bene
iniziava ragazzi sembra molto carino
live strange e nella mente non avevano
infranto del centro giocatore le
conseguenze delle azioni le decisioni
avranno effetto sul passato sul presente
e sul futuro
ok pro spiegato ho detto stai calmo se
la caverà tutto carino
oddio
salve giornata di merda è dimenticato
l'ombrello uscita di chiedersi come ti
stai pure andando a scuola quindi ancora
più merda aggiornata
va beh almeno sei una [ __ ] io vorrei
va bene
mi sembra la grafica mille volti della
gara
buon gioco punta e clicca
non è che io sia
lei
io sono io ho visto
ma anche di questo bene che tira
ok devo arrivare al faro mi chiama e
bellissimo il film ha ora gaiola mostra
grafica ve lo dico
è bellissima la grafica così è veramente
stupendo pensavo fosse punta e clicca
non hanno niente ho sbagliato lighthouse
l'andiamo a farlo niente ragazzi ci
siamo risvegliati con questa pezza
dell'oca pure si è carino parecchio sono
single e ricordo
fate intanto stanno sbattendo sui
tronchi ci siamo risvegliati che siamo
in mezzo a una tempo è la madonna ma non
è un po esagerato regalo ma serio
avevo sentito che c'era la mente o che
che metteva brutto ma non pensavo così
brutto marca vacca qua l'ombrello non ti
serve a niente credo per la siria
bentornato si no
ma veramente così grosso
mi chiama che in giornata è successo io
devo interagire durante la lezione pure
ai soci di scorcio già non sono un cazzo
di mio padre come facente regia psi
interagire con le cose norbert denef
fatti un self per le altre della lezione
ma braccio di assen software di mark
hurd max max sensi sai io so io questo
aspetto fermi nel 1715 surf a vj disse
lo sta chiedendo una canzone stessa dove
si fecero vicino a rega sai questa
macchina fotografica di starebbe bene
bene nel culo con che ragazzi interagire
in classe non è la mia dote non è mai
stata
[Musica]
io ritenni nato si ok posso già muovermi
non faccio spesso videogiochi narrativi
però questo sembra veramente carino
senti mai capilli la via 90 gradi io sei
solo tu che ti metti a 90 ma sto
scherzando il nostro scherzando dai
ragazzi fotte sega basta che usciamo
dove cui si esce di quello di prima
comunque era un sogno va bene in dubbio
fatto il servizio soprattutto che sta
facendo perché ha appoggiato la gamba
non sei [ __ ] si appoggi la gamba su sul
muro aveva aperto
ecco questa non è esattamente il tipo di
musica che mi ascolto io con le
cuffiette zia prova bene fai quello che
vuoi siamo andare bene che bello
life is strange fantastico non ho capito
ancora di che tratta pro forse di
piaggine justin sei proprio tu allora no
no non è viveur michela dietro poteva
anche sembrare case più di pai worcester
persona scomparsa dell abbandono rachel
amber me lo ricordo era quello di prima
sicuramente non era un sogno o eccomi ci
sono anch'io bagno eccolo l'ho trovato
perfetto
enti ai popoli cristina notte alla
madonna le crisi di nervi
mi sembra un po esagerato parlare di
crisi di nervi tesi è solo fatta un self
zia cioè ripigliati posso chiederti che
cosa devi fare nel bagno devi pisciare
cosa di fare distributore gli assorbenti
vortex club jerks di casa import ex club
sarebbe un club privato della scuola non
sono a posto grazie pensa chiron che lo
farò ha poi presepi dei perché c'è una
farfalla mi spiegate perchè c'è una fase
campana antincendio posso veramente fare
quello che penso a perché ho sempre
sognato di fare questa cosa ma non l'ho
mai fatto non ero io posso fare una foto
la farfalla yes
questo è il bagno delle donne al bagno
degli uomini non capito come i trust you
mi scuso
ma no aspetta veramente veramente molto
lo sapevo lo sapevo è tornata indietro
lo sapevo che non era un sogno ma va beh
non c'è parole bellissimo appena capito
di cosa tratta st gioco è bellissimo di
nicki minaj se vuoi successo sta roba
i francesi premuto il tasto destro per
riavvolgere il tempo
ma stai scherzando ma quanto figo parole
bellissime
adesso mi scappo un self e facciamo
tutto come prima ci so chi mcbride
ragazzi minchia quanto sarebbero stati
semplici di interrogazioni consensi
minchia non me lo ricordo regalo era la
risposta devo andare in bagno o riguarda
vangogh lei perché il busto di dirlo
giusto mi piaci sta però secondo me non
solo ricordano alcol e quindi non posso
torna indietro interesse riavvolge il
tempo a ok qui adesso do la risposta
giusta perché l'ha detta libro rotta
[ __ ] grazie ma posso farlo tutte le
volte che vogliono sapete che non mi
ricordo neanche adesso quale cazzola la
disperazione anche costo dolo riuscire
ad andare bene a scuola ci sono un caso
perso la dagherrotipia esatto questa
ciao subita nella lingua sun bari max
grazie va bè ragazzi allora dobbiamo
riuscire a finire st elezioni ma way
ok a posto così questo punto livelli non
immaginate che figo non so se sarei in
grado di salvare una tizia che ci ha dei
capelli blu sono i problemi per ora
abbastanza tempo per arrivare in bagno
mi chiama prima bighellonato un'ora e
mezza per la scuola figurati se non c'è
ed è perfetto poi questo era il bagno
delle donne a parte quello ok max qui
cioè acquista e m
secondo me ragazzi detto questo è
partito dalla farfalla faccio io faccio
io campanella lo sapevo che potevo farlo
o viene casualmente c'era un martello
sotto il barolo è già successo o cazzo
sorry sono lento nelle cose tranne nel
sesso veloce per lo zio
ok
o no
[Musica]
la dolce ligeia
da te no mistero
sono fatta io ho fatto ragazzi ce lo fa
con ford non so che cosa sta per
succedere adesso perché non l'ho visto
più niente da medici piazza
ways in esame col forte scoppio
a quanto mi sta simpatico sto tizio ciao
zio michè a sei un figo che adoro è il
preside
journal muscle car marine
max è bella questa è rega che ne so cosa
facciamo denunciamo nata non nascondiamo
la verità il fatto è che se denunciamo
nata io che cosa fare nella vita reale
massì dai denunciava moroni ti prego zio
con indicate l'azione fra le conseguenze
per il tempo per cambiarne l'esito
lasciato a questa zona non potrei
annullare le tue scelte ok ok quindi ho
ancora tempo per cambiare quello che ho
fatto se no me ne vado bene vado bella
va bene ragazzi 1 via episodio di life
in strange il primo spero che vi piaccia
perché un po diverso dal videogame che
faccio di solito però che figo piedi
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto fateci
sapere nei commenti cosa ne pensate cose
se vi è piaciuto sul momento e mi piace
anche a pagina di facebook e comi vizio
nei giornali siti sia di ci vediamo il
prossimo video bella ragazza